every single demon moon has suddenly
turned into hashira how strong would
they be what would be their hashira
title and which breathing style would
they use well let's find out rui the
spider hashira rui is arguably muzon's
favorite lower moon and he currently
occupies the position of lower moon 5.
as a hashira he would use spider
breathing this breathing style would be
derived from insect breathing and would
be very similar to it being the spider
hashira he would be capable of killing
demons using spider poison similar to
how shinobu the insect pillar kills
demons like spiders his breathing
techniques would give him the ability to
spawn webs using various forms these
webs would be very efficient in
capturing demons and would be so strong
and sticky that most demons except the
12 kizuki wouldn't be capable of
breaking free due to his small stature
he would be incapable of decapitating
demon's heads so rui would instead use
his spider breathing techniques to
poison the demons and kill them off hmm
this sounds really similar in terms of
personality he would be obsessed with
always being around his family and would
do everything in his power to always
protect them he would also view all of
his fellow hashira as family and would
do anything he could to protect them his
appearance as a hashiro would be very
different than his demon appearance he
would adorn his body with spider tattoos
looking like a delinquent also his white
robe would be engraved with spider web
drawings overall his appearance would be
representative of his spider breathing
technique he would definitely be a very
strong and skilled demon slayer but
compared to the other hashira he would
be the weakest enmu the dream hashira
lower moon one demon enmu is an
eccentric and very loyal demon who
possesses deep admiration for the demon
king muzon should he become a hashira he
would hold a dream pillar title his
dream breathing techniques would be
similar to hypnosis and he would be
capable of activating it with his hands
without using a sword he would be
overconfident and rely solely on his
dream breathing abilities to hypnotize
demons and leave them vulnerable waiting
to be killed nonetheless after
incapacitating demons with his
techniques he'll have to use his blade
to decapitate them his dream breathing
techniques can be activated through a
myriad of hand gestures such as clapping
waving or clicking whenever he activates
his dream breathing techniques it causes
demons to become disoriented lose
balance and become sleepy the strength
of his hypnotic abilities would be
dependent on the form he uses the first
form of his dream breathing would only
have a small hypnotic effect and the
final form would have the most powerful
effects which he would have to use for
more powerful demons such as the 12
kizuki he would be the only one amongst
the pillars who would adorn himself in
corporate attire similar to how muzon
was dressed the first time tanjuro
confronted him he would also have a
confident attitude in persona and would
possess deep admiration and respect for
ubu yashiki the leader of the demon
slayer core daki and gyutaro the blood
hashiras daki and yutaro are the only
demon turned to shiras on this list who
share the same breathing technique blood
breathing both of them would always
travel and fight together as companions
being the blood pillars they would be
capable of manipulating the blood of
their opponents this would be one of the
strongest breathing techniques but
there'd be one huge downside this
technique can only be activated once
they cut their opponents another great
ability of blood breathing would be that
any injury they inflict on weaker demons
would be incapable of healing and such
demons would lose a lot of blood in
battle daki would obviously be the
weaker among the duo with gyotaro being
the stronger one their teamwork would be
on an entirely different level than any
other pillar duo and they would both
play various roles in luring capturing
and killing demons daki being extremely
pretty as a human would appear weak
harmless and vulnerable to demons this
would serve to lure unsuspecting demons
to try and devour her only to end up
being killed by her instead and if the
demon is too strong kyotaro would step
in and finish the prey gyotaro would
have a very slim physique with scars all
over his body a result of numerous
battles he would have more hatred toward
demons than any other pillar and would
vent his anger and frustration on any
demon he came across docky being the
beauty she is would be constantly
dressed in kimono accompanied by an
umbrella which she would wield like a
sword at times gyutara on the other hand
being the carefree person he is would
always work around shirtless and looking
haggard gyoko the water hashira gyoko's
skill and pottery would make him amass a
lot of fortune a fortune that would make
him the richest demon slayer as a
hashira he would possess water breathing
his water breathing techniques would be
very similar to geyus having a large set
of techniques to choose from with some
forms being for offense and the others
for defense gyoku would also be the only
heshira who would walk around with a
huge pot of his own making strapped
around his back he would also carry his
two long swords inside his pot he would
have a modest personality despite his
riches and the only thing he'd pay
extreme importance to is his artistic
work this is why he would also be known
as the artist among the pillars and
demons would be scared to utter his name
aloud he would hold a grudge against
anyone who doesn't appreciate his art
and this is exactly the reason why he
hates demons he sees them as beings
unable to see beauty in the world and
thinks he is doing them a favor by
killing them also if anyone breaks a
piece of his art he would hunt them down
and kill them be it a demon or a human
hantengu the sound hashira as a hashira
hantenga would possess sound breathing
his soundbreathing techniques would be
activated by swinging his blade and he
would be capable of performing only
three different forms this would make
him a hashira with the fewest forms in
the entire demon slayer core the first
form would produce sonic sound waves
that can disorient demons and affect
their sense of hearing in the second
form demons would feel as if they were
about to blow up and would begin to
bleed from their ears the third form
would let him repel all sorts of attacks
using supersonic sound waves to make a
barrier around himself all of his forms
would be harmful only to demons and
wouldn't hurt humans no matter how close
they are to him hontengu as a hashira
would become a highly spiritual person
with a strong sense of justice and
kindness he would always walk around
carrying spiritual objects such as
candles books and necklaces after
killing a demon he would feel compassion
and pray for it similar to what tantro
is already doing in the show this is
because he believes all demons were once
humans and that they can't control their
bloodlust for human flesh he would also
be dressed in a spiritual robe just like
a priest he would talk very little and
overall be a mysterious character being
covered in a robe at all times his body
of physique would remain unknown akasa
the destruction hashira akasa would
probably be a fan favorite hashira being
a martial artist he would be the only
hashira who uses only his fists while
fighting demons he would not possess a
sword yes he'll be that strong he would
be the master of destructive breathing
technique this breathing technique would
amplify his strength upon activation
with this breathing style he'd be
capable of punching off the heads of any
demons even upper moons destructive
breath would possess 10 forms which
would increase his strength accordingly
with the first form doubling his base
strength and the tenth form increasing
his base strength by 20 times this would
make him by far the strongest teshira in
terms of physical strength aside from
increasing his strength his stamina and
durability would also be increased
according to the hierarchy of the forms
we previously mentioned thus he could
even tank punches from upper moon demons
being a martial artist he would always
walk around barefoot and train a lot he
would always be shirtless and he'd have
a very muscular build and cheerful
attitude since he doesn't use a sword to
fight he would have nichiren rings
around his fingers with this when he
punches a demon and beheads them the
demon won't be able to regenerate we can
safely assume that he would be the same
as he was before kaizo and koyukik were
killed a lighthearted and honest person
always ready to help and protect others
doma the ice hashira domo would be an
extremely flamboyant eccentric and
flashy hashira similar to how tangent is
in the series he would possess ice
breathing techniques he would always
volunteer to go to battles whenever the
opportunity was presented this is
because he enjoys killing demons and
testing his abilities when using his
breathing techniques steam would emanate
from his sword and he'd be capable of
using several ice resembling moves for
instance he'd be capable of shooting ice
projectiles at his targets he'd also be
capable of temporarily immobilizing his
opponents whenever he slashes them with
his sword he would do this by freezing
their body whenever they sustained a cut
from him the time a demon would remain
frozen would depend on the demon's
strength in essence the weakest demons
would be frozen for longer periods while
the stronger demons would be frozen for
extremely short periods or may not even
freeze at all in terms of defense he'd
be able to erect temporary ice walls to
block incoming attacks he'd always be
donned in royal apparel and he'd be
easily distinguishable even in big
crowds thanks to his flashy looks
kokushibo the moon hashira although it
was never officially stated that
michikatsu was a hashira he was
definitely strong enough to be one his
breathing technique the moon breathing
is the second strongest breathing
technique in the entire series because
of this he would be by far the strongest
pillar in the current generation also
he'd be the only hashiro with access to
a transparent world and selfless state
this ability would allow him to battle
even some upper moons with relative ease
assuming urichi is still alive in this
alternative universe he'd be the only
human capable of defeating kokoshibo in
combat his moon breathing techniques
were shown to be capable of sending
several attacks at the same time hence
kokushibo as a hashira should be capable
of fighting multiple demons
simultaneously he would of course still
retain his jealous personality and he'd
always strive to be the strongest he'd
always search for stronger and stronger
opponents to fight and would see this as
a means of training however being the
wielder of the great moon breathing
technique he would always prevail in
battle against any demons even upper
moons hashira kokoshiba would possess a
very long sword and he'd be dressed like
he always is in his black and purple
kimono click on this video where we
explained what would happen if all
heshira turned into demons come on click
now